bien on reprend avec l'audition de
Monsieur Proglio qui était président
d'EDF de 2009 à 2014 j'aimerais en
préambule
vous demandez de bien vouloir excuser le
retard que nous avons pris à l'occasion
de la précédente audition on avait un
peu sous dimensionné le le temps qui
nous est nécessaire à auditionner un
chef de service qui était pendant 10 ans
et c'est vrai que du coup
le nombre de questions c'est un peu
accumulé voilà monsieur le Président
nous nous remercions d'avoir accepté de
de répondre à notre invitation devant
cette commission d'enquête chargée
d'établir les raisons de la perte de
souveraineté et d'indépendance
énergétique de la France ne présentait
les changements qui sont intervenus au
cours de votre mandat de président d'EDF
entre 2009 et 2014
la semaine dernière nous avons reçu
votre prédécesseur Pierre gannenx qui
sait lui aussi
gadonex pardon
qui lui aussi c'est aimablement plié à
cet exercice cette audition comme celle
des autres dirigeants d'entreprises que
nous avons entendu nous ont nous a
d'ailleurs permis de prendre conscience
de la variété des questions que vous
avez à traiter et des conditions dans
lesquelles des priorités peuvent être
définies ou des opportunités saisies
elle a révélé aussi l'enjeu important
pour les pouvoirs publics que
représentaient et représentent toujours
le contrôle ou la maîtrise des tarifs de
l'électricité les années au cours
desquelles vous avez exercer les
fonctions de président d'EDF ont été
marquées notamment par le Grenelle de
l'environnement et c'est suite par
l'adoption de la loi du 7 décembre 2010
portant nouvelle organisation du marché
de l'électricité qui a mis en place le
dispositif de l'accès régulier à
l'énergie nucléaire historique
par l'accident de Fukushima en 2011 et
par la décision prise par l'Allemagne de
sortir du nucléaire ainsi qu'en France
la poursuite du chantier de Flamanville
3 si on essaie de prendre en
considération l'échelon européen votre
mandat a été rythmé par une
communication sur la politique
énergétique de l'Union européenne un
règlement pour les infrastructures
énergétiques trans-européennes la
stratégie pour une union de l'énergie
des directives sur l'efficacité
énergétique et la promotion de
l'utilisation de l'énergie produite à
partir de source renouvelables les
règlements sur le marché intérieur de
l'électricité et sur la préparation au
risque dans le secteur de l'électricité
et enfin le règlement instituant
l'agence de l'Union européenne pour la
coopération des régulateurs de l'énergie
ça en fait
dans le domaine économique la crise
financière de 2008 continuait là aussi à
la prise de votre fonction de produire
ses effets et il s'agit là que de
quelques éléments qui nous permettent
collectivement de nous repositionner
dans le contexte qui a été celui de
votre mandat je ne doute pas comme nous
avons pu le voir d'ailleurs lors des
précédentes auditions que les échanges
que nous pouvons avoir avec vous auront
ce caractère qui est celui des
industriels d'être clair et direct
contrairement à ce qui est parfois le
cas dans les administrations ou c'est
plus confus pour essayer de comprendre
certaines choses voilà je vais donc vous
laisser monsieur provilliau la parole
pour un propos introductif mais avant
cela il me revient de vous demander en
vertu de l'article 6 de l'ordonnance du
17 novembre 1958 de bien vouloir prêter
serment de dire la vérité toute la
vérité et rien que la vérité je vous
prie donc de bien vouloir lever la main
droite et dire je le jure je le jure je
vous remercie et je vous laisse la
parole merci Monsieur Brison merci
Monsieur rapporteur mesdames et
Messieurs les parlementaires mesdames et
messieurs bon je vais essayer d'être
rapide dans mon propos liminaire de
manière à ne pas vous faire subir
d'abord
de l'empalabre et puis répondre surtout
à vos questions qui me paraissent plus
pertinent que ce que je peux avoir vous
dire il reste que
le thème que vous évoquez est essentiel
l'indépendance énergétique et
et par conséquent la situation actuelle
ne le rend que plus sensible
j'avais envie de vous donner quelques
visions mon point de vue de ce qui a été
et ce qui est devenu
l'énergie enfin l'électricité française
pourquoi et comment nous sommes devenus
un grand
énergéticien et pourquoi la France a eu
cette indépendance
dont elle a bien bénéficié pendant des
années comment on en est arrivé à la
situation actuelle au fond c'est cette
perspective là que je voudrais tracer
dans vous avant de répondre à vos
questions sur l'action que j'ai menée ou
sur les sujets divers que vous aurez
traité
pour qu'il me concerne j'ai été
administrateur indépendant d'EDF de 2005
à 2009
j'étais à l'époque président de Veolia
grande entreprise privée de délégation
de service public je ne sais pas si ça a
eu un impact sur le choix de ma personne
j'ai l'impression que oui et c'est comme
ça que j'arrive en fin 2009 en novembre
2009 à la tête de DF
formidable entreprise
donc je rappelle qu'à l'époque elle
était au CAC 40 une des grandes valeurs
françaises du CAC 40
qualités accessoirement l'entreprise
préférée des Français
et que l'été dans le monde entier connu
pour sa pertinence et son efficacité
juste donc très fier d'arriver à la tête
de cette formidable entreprise
à peu près 80 petits 80 milliards 97
milliards de chiffre d'affaires et
dont les caractéristiques financières on
pourra les rappeler tout à l'heure était
très satisfaisante
j'avais la fierté de prendre la
responsabilité d'une entreprise
dont je pensais que c'était une
entreprise de service public
elle est identifiée comme tel partout
dans le monde c'était le premier
opérateur européen probablement mondial
si on accepte la Chine dont les contours
des opérateurs
plusieurs opérateurs d'ailleurs ne sont
pas faciles à cerner
alors qu'est-ce que c'est que DF
qu'est-ce qui quel est cette entreprise
elle a été le résultat d'une formidable
aventure mais surtout d'une vision et
d'une volonté celle d'un gouvernement
qui en 1947 46 puisque c'est la date de
création de DF
a considéré que l'énergie est donc
l'électricité était un élément essentiel
de la vie économique et qu'il était donc
important de la considérer comme
stratégique
ce gouvernement là
a pris conscience du fait que la France
n'avait pas beaucoup de matières
premières avaient peu de gaz
pratiquement pas peu de tir bon par
rapport à ses voisins
et que par conséquent elle était
totalement dépendante de ces
importations en matière d'électricité en
matière d'énergie en général
d'électricité en particulier
et elle s'est lancée
le gouvernement de l'époque s'est lancé
trois défis majeurs le défi de
l'indépendance énergétique le défi de la
compétitivité du territoire
et parce que à l'époque le gouvernement
a été l'alliance entre les gaullistes et
les communistes
le défi du service public de
l'électricité
pour concevoir un service public
accessible à tous et que tous les
Français quel que soit leur classe
sociale quel que soit le lieu de
résidence sur le territoire en France
métropolitaine et outre-mer avait droit
à l'électricité de la même qualité au
même prix
c'était donc un défi incroyablement
exigeant
il était entrepris adossé à un choix
technologique clair
l'hydraulique et le nucléaire
qui ont conduit des errements parce que
c'est vrai que quand on parle du
nucléaire il y a eu des phases de choix
technologiques dont je ne rappellerai
pas le détail parce qu'ils sont mais on
est parti avec des jouets technologiques
qui ont évolué dans le temps toujours
est-il qu'il y a eu une continuité une
vision à long terme et une volonté
claire d'aboutir et c'est ça qui a donné
naissance à cette aventure industrielle
et puis évidemment avec une filière une
filière comprenant
un outil pour la recherche qui était le
CEVA
et puis deux entreprises adossées à EDF
qui était Framatome et
que j'ai ma l'une pour la partie
industrielle de fabrication l'autre pour
la partie retraitement et donc cet
ensemble qui constitue la filière
nucléaire française
EDF a été considéré comme étant
l'architecte ensemblier d'ensemble et
l'opérateur du service public de
l'électricité
système
j'asserai là-dessus intégrer cohérent et
optimisé comprenant la production le
transport la distribution
un contrat service public qui fait
référence dans le monde et donna la
France un atout formidable en matière
d'émission de gaz à effet de serre les
quatre Paris ont été relevés
il n'y avait plus qu'à tout détruire
ces choses faites
pourquoi comment
puisqu'on est arrivé à la symptômes
comment est-ce qu'on arrive à sectuelle
c'est ça que je voudrais évoquer aussi
de vos journées
moi je vois deux acteurs principaux
l'Europe et le gouvernement français
on peut en discuter l'Europe
tout est la réglementation européenne
depuis 10 ans
ne vise
conséquence que la désintégration
de l'entreprise de
cette Europe qui a pris comme axe
idéologique quasi unique la concurrence
qui bien sûr fait le bonheur des peuples
on voit ce que ça donne en matière
d'énergie
et qui s'est traduit comment en terme
concret pour l'entreprise EDF 1 quand
j'arrive à la tête de cette maison on
nous parle que d'une chose traumatisante
absolue la mise en concurrence des
barrages
formidable idée un barrage étant
essentiellement un outil d'optimisation
du système électrique puisqu'il est le
seul
la seule pile combustible intelligente
et efficace qu'on est aujourd'hui un
barrage sert d'abord à stocker beaucoup
plus qu'à produire donc la mise en
concurrence consistait à supprimer le
stockage c'est génial et on voyait
débarquer sur nos sites des Canadiens
des Allemands des Russes des Chinois
enfin tout le monde allez visiter les
barrages puisque alors il se trouve que
le barrage appartiennent à l'État et
sont gérés par EDF
envisagé d'obéir à la doctrine
européenne et de mettre en concurrence
les barrages je me suis battu
évidemment avec l'ensemble de
l'entreprise
rien n'a été conclu mais rien ne réglé
on reste en lévitation on sait pas règle
européenne existe toujours on l'a pas
encore respecté on sera sanctionné sans
doute
la deuxième moi géniale c'est la loi
d'un homme que vous avez rappelé qui
sont consiste à imposer à EDF la vente a
pris casser puisque inférieur au coût de
revient de 25% de sa production
électronucléaire assez propre
concurrents pour qu'ils puissent vendre
son énergie à l'heure au client de EDF
ça a très bien fonctionné ils sont
devenus riches
c'est d'une pertinence absolue
je l'ai dénoncé pendant des années avec
l'efficacité que vous voyez
et puis pour couronner le tout il
fallait quand même définir un prix de
marché puisqu'il n'y avait pas de marché
défini un prix de marché prix de marché
qui a été indexé sur quoi sur le gaz je
vais me dire pourquoi sur le gaz
puisqu'on n'utilise pas parce que les
Allemands utilisent le gaz
et que toutes ces démarches c'est une
démarche allemande tout argumentation
européenne réglementation allemande
alors je ferai une petite parenthèse qui
est politique pas encore plus incorrecte
c'est que l'Allemagne
disons le franchement
a depuis depuis la création de
République
choisi
l'industrie comme Max majeur de son
économie a choisi l'os politique pour
son développement
c'est clair et c'est cohérent d'ailleurs
pour ce pays que l'Allemagne
[Musique]
accepte que la France dispose d'un outil
compétitifs aussi puissant que des f à
sa porte l'obsession allemande depuis 30
ans c'est la désintégration de des
ils ont réussi
et
pour couronner le tout il fallait
évidemment séparer les réseaux de
distribution et de transport du reste
c'est à dire que EDF aujourd'hui une
espèce de
d'Autriche Hongrie rabougri c'est à dire
que
c'est il y a eu un empire et puis
une société qui est un producteur
d'énergie électrique qui n'a plus accès
à ses clients
dans son optimisation dépend d'une
société RTE qui est en lévitation
et
tout ça va dans le sens de la
des optimisation totale du système
auquel nous avons droit aujourd'hui
le deuxième acteur quand même du paysage
c'est la politique nationale française
là je serai très très
respectueux mais enfin vous connaissez
le sujet bien mieux que moi
on a assisté à la recherche pathétique
d'un accord électoral avec un parti
antinucléaire dont la seule doctrine
était celle-là alors on envoie les
prémices de 1997 1998 avec l'abandon de
directeur à notre rapide première
je dirais
infraction dans le système qui remettait
en cause la logique du système nucléaire
français ensuite il y a eu évidemment
Fukushima et la formidable opération
médiatique autour de Fukushima les 20000
morts de Fukushima qui n'ont jamais
existé puisqu'on a confondu le tsunami
et l'accident et puis l'apogée quand
même puisqu'il y a toujours une apogée
c'est quand même la campagne de 2012
avec
son cortège de
de joyeusetés la fermeture envisagée et
annoncée de 28 réacteurs nucléaires bon
rien que ça et puis qui sait qui s'est
transformé progressivement parce qu'il
fallait quand même pour une sortie
par l'engagement sur la fermeture de
Fessenheim bon mais l'engagement de
baisser à 50 % la production
électronucléaire française enfin la part
du nucléaire électrique
alors mieux que ça parce que j'ai
assisté évidemment les bras
avec beaucoup de désespoir à la mise au
point d'une théorie absurde qui m'a été
imposée à l'époque avec beaucoup
d'insistance par les pouvoirs publics
qui étaient les théorie de la
décroissance électrique
il était de bontons d'accepter l'idée
degrés ou de force qui fallait
considérer que la demande électrique
allait baisser en France et que par
conséquent le nucléaire était
surpuissant qui fait en diminuer la
puissance
alors tout ça a eu comme conséquence
d'abord la baisse des efforts de
recherche évidemment le désalignement
des stratégies des entreprises
dépendantes des tests c'est-à-dire CE1
EDF
qui ont été
mis par des courants divergents
avec comme corollaire l'affaiblissement
évidemment globale du système et
j'allais le dire presque anecdotiquement
mais c'est essentiel les difficultés de
recrutement Kodak connu c'est à dire que
dans ce paysage ou le nucléaire était
considéré comme infâme et où il fallait
absolument baisser une considérer qu'il
n'y avait pas d'avenir au nucléaire
comment voulez-vous recruter des gens
compétents
le nucléaire avait disposé des
meilleures compétences possibles dans ce
pays qui sait fabriquer des heures très
haut niveau mais
on considérer je vous demande de m'en
excuser que des ne surpeille pas ses
collaborateurs très bon niveau sont
normalement payés mais pas sur rémunérer
donc les différentiels de rémunération
entre l'industrie et la finance sont
devenus gigantesques entre l'industrie
privée et EDF l'écart c'est encore
creusé et pour finir on vous dit vous
n'avez pas d'avenir et vous devriez
avoir honte de ce que vous faites
évidemment c'est très attractif et donc
on a depuis 10 ans une panne de
recrutement de gens de qualité qui va se
sentir aujourd'hui quand au hasard ext
on veut relancer le nucléaire voilà la
situation
alors rien n'est jamais désespéré mais
les choses ont été très très abîmée
je considère que
le constat
aujourd'hui est facile parce que
quelques éléments extérieurs ont fait
que
s'impose à nous assez naturellement
alors qu'on le voyait depuis des années
et que je l'ai dénoncé depuis très
longtemps
et face à ce constat que faire pour
redresser la situation
on va y venir moi je pense qu'il faut
se consacrer à des sujets prioritaires
il y a des actions prioritaires la
réflexion est faite c'est l'action qui
doit aujourd'hui être menée
si j'osais je vous dirai donner donc la
priorité au développement
au développement de l'hydraulique il y a
encore des opportunités d'accélérer dans
l'hydraulique en France pourquoi hésiter
pourquoi attendre
et puis faisons ce qu'il faut pour
sécuriser le prolongement de la durée de
vie de paru clair existant si on faisait
l'un et l'autre
on pourrait progressivement redresser la
barre et se donner le temps de relancer
le nucléaire parce qu'il faudra 10 à 15
ans pour renoncer le nouveau nucléaire
ça se fera pas du jour au lendemain
voilà monsieur le Président
sans détour quelques
[Musique]
explications sur ce que j'ai vécu
merci beaucoup sur le président pour ses
propos très clairs et compréhensible de
tous
j'aurais quelques questions une première
qui concerne
les mécanismes européens que vous avez
déjà un peu un peu décrit la loi nomme
la rend et son absence d'évolution
la question d'abord c'est comment parce
que tout ça a mis en place sous votre
enfin au moment où vous êtes président
de
votre mandat comment est défini le tarif
de la rang comment les mécanismes
d'évolution sont-ils à leur imaginés et
pourquoi est-ce que ça bloque à un
moment donné
bon le tarif la reine puisque c'est
comme ça que
on l'appelait à l'époque et qu'on
l'appelle toujours aujourd'hui
ma value des combats homériques puisque
l'État voulait absolument qu'il soit
fixé à 39 €. on hésité enfin 36 avait
été évoqué puis 39
je me suis battu
sans relâche pour obtenir 42 euros ce
qui était
inimaginable à l'époque pour mes
interlocuteurs
aucune évolution n'a été évidemment
prise en compte
je voulais me faire la confidence qu'à
ce moment-là on est en 2012
dans mon combat contre les
administrations compétentes on va réputé
[Musique]
j'ai laissé filer la réglementation
thermique 2012 tant le combat sur
l'arène était compliqué
et je me suis tant pis je sacrifice
combat là qui conduit aujourd'hui une
catastrophe puisque comme vous le savez
il favorise totalement le gaz
voilà quelques souvenirs donc ça a été
fixé
tu as été fixé par
par voie autoritaire au bout d'une fois
d'un combat
très inégal puisque j'ai essayé de
défendre le bon sens donc j'étais donc
dans le mauvais quand mais
le principe même de
ce prix de session était absurde puisque
le principe même pour un industriel
d'accepter de céder sa propre production
assez concurrents virtuels qui n'ont
aucune obligation de production même
donc on a fait le la fortune de trader
pas d'industriels
n'a pas de concurrent
si peu
quelques éoliennes qui sont dispersés ou
quatre jours et quelque chose
[Musique]
du sujet non c'est et vous voyez des
campagnes de communication de ces
traders qui prétendent vendre de
l'énergie verte
je vous vends de l'énergie verte
c'est la mienne
on a assisté à ça pendant des années
avant que le client qui lui-même s'est
laissé abuser finissent par se rendre
compte du fait que
il avait plus de garantie
cette fameuse garantie d'anticiper au
fond félicité pendant des années puisque
le tarif régulé lui permettait d'avoir
une visibilité une certitude une
garantie une cohérence
tout ça a disparu
où est le service public de
l'électricité qui nous a tant et tant
récompensé
pourquoi l'avoir abattu
pourquoi est-ce que c'est à l'État
aujourd'hui de faire les compensations
nécessaires pour que les gens fait
revenir puissent accéder à une capacité
tout ça a été prévu
on nous a décrit au cours d'une
précédente audition
une forme de mécanisme de
chantage autour de la révision du tarif
de la rang
et quotidien et des concessions
hydroélectriques qui sont dans une
espèce d'impasse est-ce que c'est
quelque chose que vous avez déjà vécu
puisque à partir de demain
revalorisé ça ne m'a jamais tellement
impressionné mais j'ai vu que tous les
avantages
le seul avantage qui m'obsède c'est
l'intérêt de la France
pourquoi prendre la France un otage de
ce genre de réglementation absurde
comment est-ce qu'on explique cette
réglementation je voudrais que qu'on est
simplement la question de fond c'est
pour qui à quoi
servent ces réglementations
quel est le but
alors à chaque fois on me dit oui mais
le but comprenez on fait le bonheur du
peuple
concurrence mais il y a qu'un seul
producteur camarade
concurrence
il était clair que ça
se traduire par un désastre
on y assiste aujourd'hui
alors
vous allez dans votre propos introductif
évoqué la
[Musique]
théorie de la décroissance de la du
besoin électrique qui apparaît à partir
de 2012 est-ce que vous avez le
sentiment que RTE a contribué à abonder
cette théorie avec des études supposées
techniques
lequel RTU avant ou le RTU d'après
non
les technocrates sont
courants avec eux-mêmes si vous voulez
vous pouvez extrapoler
donc il suffit d'extrapoler le fait que
les économies d'énergie peuvent être
exprès à l'infini et dont vous baissez
une demande d'énergie tout court
d'énergie électrique en particulier
mais ils sont nombreux donc il faut
qu'il s'occupe à faire des
extrapolations donc
[Musique]
mais comment voulez-vous l'expliquer à
quelqu'un qui serait simplement
quelqu'un de bon sens
si on avait mis un artisan boulanger la
tête de la direction générale de
l'énergie il aurait probablement pas
réagi comme ça
et du coup ça me mène à une autre
question puisque en fait vous avez vécu
ce basculement en 2012 il y a une
question à laquelle on n'a pas encore
trouvé de réponse
c'est d'où viennent les 50% qui
constituent l'objectif de part du
nucléaire dans le mix électrique
français
le reste 50 les autres 50%
dans la tête CV la loi de 2015 on dit
l'objectif du nucléaire c'est 50%.
pourquoi 50%, enfin comment se construit
ce chiffre de votre point de vue
complètement au dos mouillé
en disant tout ne sera pas nucléaire on
va baisser la part du nucléaire donc
vous êtes à 75% enfin on était un peu au
dessus plus personne ne sait faire les
calculs enfin c'est pas grave donc ils
ont dit de 575 il faut faire une
ristourne tu prends quoi toi bah allez
10 50
personnes n'a jamais estimé autrement
que comme ça
et puisqu'on a ensuite rajuster
puisqu'il faut être à 50 il faut baisser
le nombre de réacteurs
puisque non seulement on va baisser la
consommation d'électricité mais on va
diminuer la part du nucléaire
donc il est légitime de réduire le
nombre de réacteurs
j'aurais une personne n'a jamais su d'où
venait les autres 50% par contre
il y a l'hydraulique quand même qui
renouvelable
une très belle énergie le reste du
renouvelable c'est c'est l'expérience
allemande ils ont investi 500 milliards
d'euros dans le renouvelable
il arrive 500 milliards d'euros on
envoie l'efficacité
en ce moment qui nous permet de
finalement tenir l'hiver charbon
allemand et la limite n'oubliez pas la
ligne
moi j'aurai une dernière question avant
de passer la main au rapporteur qui est
plus sur la filière
à l'époque
où vous dirigez EDF existe encore Areva
et les batailles homériques que arriva
et EDF semaine pour
vendre des EPR le même EPR au même
client comment vous percevez cela
personne donc
on a vendu
arriva prétendez vendre des admets
je ne vous dirai c'est un petit pair de
1000 mégawatt qui n'a jamais existé
il m'est arrivé à Matignon dans une
réunion parce que là aussi on a eu des
moments
assez puissants
le gouvernement avait décidé que des
fêter le chef de fil de la fier
nucléaire française bon j'étais comme ça
j'ai hérité de cette responsabilité par
la fonction que j'ai exercé
le nouveau gouvernement de l'époque
pas du tout c'est le premier ministre
qui est
le patron de la filière nucléaire
alors vous connaissez le Premier
ministre il avait été maire de Nantes je
connaissais relativement bien mais
fonction précédente
je le voyais un peu gêné alors il
organisait des réunions à Matignon
de répartition des rôles
du roi c'était
il y avait 11 ministres les 11
directeurs de cabinets 20 patrons de
l'administration et puis trois pellets
c'est à dire mestrale
et on se répartissait les développements
du nouveau nucléaire à l'international
on a assisté à des réunions j'ai assisté
à des réunions qui étaient
autant couleurs toujours
le roi de Jordanie était venu à Paris
une fois de plus il était venu déjà lors
du précédent gouvernement dire aux
Français vous devriez me vendre au
réacteur nucléaire mais je veux en 900
MW du parc existant vous ne vous vendez
community
vous me l'envoyer
et quand même le gouvernement lui dit
bah non on peut pas c'est pas mobile
donc on va vous construire un recteur
et
Premier ministre dit bon alors qui
Jordanie c'est qui
regarde ses chaussures donc je dis c'est
Gérard
ah vous faites un cadeau à Australie
Jordanie c'est lui il n'osait pas dire
non et
pourquoi vous faites ce cadeau je dis
parce qu'un jour Dany il y a pas d'eau
pour refroidir et pas d'argent pour
payer donc c'est autant que ça soit lui
après on allait vendre des admets à la
Turquie je dis c'est
[Musique]
la répartition était assez simple
alors est venu sur la table évidemment
la Grande-Bretagne puisque c'était à
l'époque où on commençait la négociation
sur une pierre britannique
moi je veux bien mais EDF a racheté
c'était mon prédécesseur que de
l'interroger il avait racheté British
énergy qui est devenu des énergies on
était donc propriétaire de tous les
sites nucléaires britanniques
si vous voulez vous nous racheter ça et
puis vous faites le développement que
vous voulez mais tant que je suis
propriétaire des sites
donc l'affaire était vite réglée aussi
voilà pas tellement de débats
[Musique]
mais pour autant il y avait une ambition
de d'arriva de devenir un vendeur de
centrale nucléaire
par la dérive d'arriver oui on a vu ce
que ça donnait et elle était où cette
dérive au-delà de cela
la vanité
non mais arriva était avait
sa mission c'était d'être chaudronné
d'une part et
de gérer les centres de recrutement
bon voilà alors vouloir vendre concevoir
et vendre des réacteurs c'était pas son
métier bon
on a vu les conséquences de cela
dans la conception d'abord de l'EPR
dont on aurait beaucoup à dire et dans
la réussite phénoménale de
qui a cloué le cercueil d'un Eva et puis
voilà donc
alors arrivé ensuite en dépôt de bilan
il a fallu
c'est une autre histoire
merci monsieur le Président merci
monsieur le Président aussi pour ces
premières réponses je vais essayer
d'être assez synthétique vous arrivez à
la tête de def en 2009 mais vous êtes
administrateur chez EDF depuis 2005
dans quel état vous trouvez l'entreprise
en terme de capacité d'investissement de
compétences le moral des troupes si vous
me passez l'expression et de projection
dans l'avenir en termes de production
d'énergie nucléaire production d'énergie
renouvelable
il est
[Musique]
traditionnel que nouvelle arrivante
trouve beaucoup de défauts à son
prédécesseur et bien sûr à son
successeur
où je trouve une maison en assez bon
état
avec de très belles compétences
je dois reconnaître que
j'étais
très heureux de la densité des
compétences de la maison que j'ai trouvé
à mon arrivée
financièrement
sans
énormes difficultés EDF avait quand même
financé tout pour un nucléaire puisque
on oublie de le mentionner enfin c'est
quand même EDF qui a financé le problème
nucléaire français
et l'endettement de la société Anne et
la résultat mais au fond l'endettement
de DF était parfaitement acceptable et
bon
rien de
fond je n'ai pas trouvé une maison en
mauvais état j'ai essayé de donner une
impulsion supplémentaire
j'ai fait quelques arbitrages j'ai vendu
donc l'Allemagne comme je vous le disais
j'ai repris le contrôle de l'Italie
puisque on était planté avec une fille
italienne détignons 40% qui est Edison
et dont nous avions deux et demi pour
cent des droits de vote donc j'ai réglé
le problème on a pris le contrôle des
Nissan par échange de titre avec les
organisations de des États-Unis du Nord
donc sans débourser d'argent
et puis j'ai mené à bien la négociation
du contrat britannique sur nucléaire
britannique donc on pourrait sur lequel
on pourrait revenir
j'ai quitté la maison avec
émotion en fin d'année 2014 comme vous
le savez
et au fond avec un bilan qui a été
arrêté par mon successeur par définition
parce que quand on quitte une entreprise
à la fin de l'année c'est le qui
arrête le compte
2014 c'est
[Musique]
78 milliards de chiffre d'affaires c'est
17 millions et demi d'habitat
3750 millions de résultats net après
impôts meilleurs résultats que des FF
est fait dans toute sa vie
et une ratio d'être sur Ibiza vous savez
que il sera à peu près à calculer le
niveau d'endettement puisque c'est pas
la valeur absolue qui compte qui était
légèrement inférieur à 3 c'est-à-dire
parfaitement acceptable dans les normes
les plus sévères
je j'en félicite des équipes parce que
c'est pas travailler individuel mais EDF
était en pleine forme malgré malgré
toutes les vicitudes à laquelle nous
avons été soumises à la fois par soumis
pardon à la fois par les réglementations
françaises et européenne les lois non
mais compagnie
donc on avait survécu à tout cela
évidemment ça abîme durablement les
performances de l'entreprise on en a vu
les conséquences mais voilà ce que je
peux dire avec déjà quand même une
préoccupation en matière de
matière sociale si je puis dire je n'ai
pas eu de problème sociaux au cours de
mes 5 années pas de grève on climat
social apaisé
mais une préoccupation en matière de
formation que je trouvais
à renforcer donc j'ai créé un centre de
formation dédié de manière à renforcer
la capacité de formation des équipes au
sens large j'ai pas uniquement des cas
dirigeant et d'autre part une
préoccupation alors de fond qui était ce
que je vous disais tout à l'heure le
sujet du renouvellement des cadres du
nucléaire
qui est un sujet auquel on n'a pas
réussi à porter une vraie réponse pour
des raisons que je vous rappelez c'est à
dire le désamour du nucléaire dans
l'opinion publique et dans les médias et
le fait qu'on
respectait une norme de rémunération qui
était assez exigeante
merci
à votre arrivée ou quasi simultanément
ce produit donc face le rapport Chanceur
est rendu au ministre de l'époque
Jean-Louis Borloo qui met en oeuvre
l'une des deux préconisations
principales du rapport qui est ce qui
devient la reine vous avez dit que vous
avez à de nombreuses reprises alertées
est-ce que c'est à dire que vous avez
des entretiens avec le ministre de
l'époque pour lui expliquer que vous
considérez que c'était une erreur et une
faute industrielle pour EDF
très bien quel a été la réponse apportée
politique
c'est-à-dire je comprends je comprends
je comprends
oui
qu'est-ce qu'on fait
il arrive au moment où la décision
l'emporte sur les réflexions et ce
moment on peut pas l'éterniser et je
trouve que cette démarche encore une
fois cette mesure était unique n'était
destiné
casser la logique de l'entreprise comme
EDF
je déplore qu'elle était acceptée par le
gouvernement français sous la pression
bien sûr borussiello allemande
alors je n'ai pas la vanité de décider à
la place du politique
j'ai simplement souhaité alerté pendant
toute ma période de responsabilité
vous succédez aussi donc à Pierre
gatonex qui nous a expliqué dans son
lors de son audition
qui s'était battu pour faire remonter
les investissements def en particulier
en France et qu'il avait notamment
alerté le gouvernement depuis de
nombreuses années sur la question du
prix de l'électricité et la capacité
pour EDF avant même la reine a investir
dans un monde où le prix d'énergie ne
reflétait pas les investissements
nécessaires j'imagine qu'il vous
transmet cette alerte en arrivant quelle
réflexion ça vous inspire est-ce que
vous en parlez également au pouvoir
public et évidemment
j'ai négocié avec les pouvoirs publics
les pouvoirs publics au plus haut niveau
une pente tarifaire je pensais qu'il
fallait plutôt que de procéder par des
augmentations
successives avoir une visibilité c'est
mieux pour tout le monde d'avoir une
forme d'indexation des tarifs sur une
projection qui permet à chacun de gérer
ces contraintes au fond je crois
beaucoup plus à cela alors peut-être à
mon ancien métier d'opérateur délégué de
service public mais dans la distribution
d'eau ou dans les déchets on a des
formules de variation de prix qui sont
négociées à l'avance et qui permettent
d'anticiper des évolutions tarifaires
des plusieurs années à l'avance de
manière à ce que à la fois les
responsables politiques puissent
on prendra deuxièmement qui puisse
secourir les gens qui ont besoin d'être
aidé et tout cela se fait dans une
espèce de continuum beaucoup plus
rationnelle donc j'ai négocié ça je
reconnais que j'ai obtenu
une pente tarifaire
de mon interlocuteur
mais
quelques mois plus tard elle a été
cassée par un décret
du ministre de la ministre j'ai eu 750
donc ne cherchez pas là aussi ça fait
partie des USD du sujet puisqu'on
investit sur des durées très longues
c'est une ton métier on gère le temps
long les investissements on les amortit
sur 40-50 ans pour les barrages en tout
cas non pas
comptablement mais économique
dans la durée de vie de dépasse pas 9
mois et quelque chose assez difficile à
gérer
dip pour l'avoir vécu
donc chaque ministre évidemment
très demandeur de communication d'une
part et puis
d'attacher son nom à quelque chose qui
soit populaire donc le fait de
prendre la décision de
de refuser l'augmentation des prix
électricité
était effectivement à court terme
relativement populaire j'ai eu droit à
ça aussi
donc c'est une discussion
inévitablement complexe avec des
pouvoirs publics sous toutes leurs
formes mais en fait tout ça remonte
assez vite des très haut niveau parce
que personne ne peut prendre cette
décision sans avoir au fond Laval et
l'accord explicite du politique et je
comprends que le politique soit en
difficulté pour augmenter les tarifs et
c'est la raison pour laquelle je
suggérais qui est
font une gestion commune au travers
d'une pompe à faire j'ai toujours la
faiblesse de portrait que c'était la
bonne solution
donc vous décrivez à votre arrivée une
entreprise globalement en bon état y
compris du point de vue de la santé
financière et des compétences il y a un
projet néanmoins à votre arrivée qui
doit vous interroger c'est celui de
l'EPR de Flamanville d'abord vous étiez
en 2005 en arrivant on lance un seul
réacteur la construction d'un seul
réacteur en mai 2006 le coût est estimé
c'est le rapport fold qui qui donne ses
chiffres à peu près à 3 milliards
d'euros avec une mise en service prévue
en juin 2012 ça c'est le bouquin de
référence d'arriver quand vous arrivez
légèrement après en juillet 2010 le coup
est de 5 milliards avec un couplage
prévu au réseau en 2014 et en novembre
2014 on est à peu près à 9 milliards
d'euros et un démarrage prévu en 2017 à
la fois quand vous étiez pas encore
président DF puis ensuite est-ce que
vous pouvez nous expliquer ce qui s'est
passé selon vous
malheureusement oui
le père est un engin beaucoup trop
compliqué quasi inconstructible enfin on
en voit aujourd'hui
les difficultés
les grands patrons du nucléaire d'EDF
la vie anticipé
mais la dérive encore une fois
d'organisation du
du système nucléaire et la prédominance
d'Areva dans ce dispositif pour des
raisons non techniques et absurdes fait
que c'était le seul outil qui est
disponible sur
dans notre dans notre univers
je vais péter en étant administrateur
indépendant contre les avenants
au contrat de construction de
l'entreprise de construction on était au
15e avenant pas tous les trois mois on
avait un avenant qui était porté la
connaissance du Conseil j'avais dit mais
enfin c'est un contrôle forfait comment
est-ce que on peut j'ai donc vu le
patron d'entreprise de construction qui
dont le patronyme bien connu qui est le
constructeur de Flamanville en disant
écoute c'est pas possible il me dit bien
avec moi on va sur le site et là bon
c'est vrai que et alors l'entreprise
dans une situation relativement
confortable en disant tu sais si j'ai
pas l'avenant j'arrête les travaux
parce que je peux pas m'en sortir j'ai
déjà perdu 250 millions donc j'arrête
et donc vous passez le 17ème 18ème 19e
le 20e à venant
c'est une vie sans fin
j'ai eu la faiblesse de d'annoncer pour
2014 la connexion au réseau parce que
mes ingénieurs m'avaient dit écoutez
chef
pour annoncer 2000 allez 2012 ça devrait
coller quoi
j'ai pris deux ans de marge
donc non il y a un vrai problème de le
père
que je comprends pas en fait c'est
comment un tel projet
enfin comment il peut y avoir un tel
décalage c'est à dire comment est-ce que
des années j'ai intolérable et en même
temps mais je revois le conception de
l'UPR il faut revoir le jeu à nouveau on
cherche pas des fautes individuelles ce
qu'on essaye de comprendre c'est ce qui
peut permettre à des ingénieurs chez EDF
d'aller expliquer au président directeur
général un délai et un coût qui
manifestement ne sont même pas
envisageables d'un point de vue
technique numetrisable j'ai changé les
équipes
j'ai pas réussi à changer le père mais
encore une fois on a la conjugué entre
deux phénomènes le premier phénomène
c'est la complexité du design de l'EPR
qui est totalement au revoir et donc on
avait déjà initié travail en commun avec
arriva de l'époque après le départ de
Madame le Verjon pour concevoir un EPR
nouveau
PR2
qu'on croyait destiné à la Pologne enfin
vous avez vu que la Pologne avait acheté
américain mais enfin bon de manière à ce
qu'on tire les
de tous les toutes les erreurs de départ
de la deuxième raison
c'est le fait que la filière nucléaire
française n'a plus construit de nouveaux
réacteurs depuis 20 ans
et
le savoir-faire en matière de maintenant
a été bien maîtrisé en matière de
construction nouvelle
donc
c'est la raison pour laquelle je moi
j'ai imaginé c'est l'orientation que
j'avais donné au cours de mon mandat
qui fallait repenser le Pr complètement
refaire un réacteur
différent nouveau design ça allait nous
prendre 10 à 12 ans mise au point
et que pendant ce temps-là vous pouvez
pas laisser la filière nucléaire
sans carnet de commande
le grand carénage c'est à dire en fait
le les investissements de rénovation du
parc existant ne suffisant pas et par
conséquent je pensais à une coopération
avec les Chinois les Russes à l'époque
qui était ceux qui développaient du
niveau nucléaire il se construit
directement chaque année en Chine et les
Russes ont aujourd'hui à peu près 40
réacteurs en commande dans des grandes
villes nouveaux acteurs et donc je
pensais qu'il était bon pour la fille
française de ne pas être absent et que
par conséquent en attendant qu'on est
réacteur français que nos entreprises
puissent travailler sur du nouveau du
nouveau nucléaire
on en connaît la suite mais voilà
comment j'avais imaginé l'évolution du
sujet
d'accord je comprends qu'il y a quand
même une question de compétence quand
vous arrivez aux responsabilités à la
tête de DF parce que la finale le
dernier réacteur a été mis en service au
début des années 2000 donc on n'est pas
à l'époque il y a pas un si grand
déficit de compétences j'imagine si on
met le dernier réacteur
d'expérience des sous-traitants
de construction d'accord
parce que
l'effet de série qui avait tellement
réussi à la France on a construit
jusqu'à cinq réacteurs par an au moment
de réalisation du parc a eu un effet
extrêmement positif sur la filière le
fait de neuro plus construit depuis 15
ans puisque la mise en service veut dire
qu'il était reconstruit donc
à un impact extrêmement négatif sur la
même pierre
le BTP l'industrie lourde
la chaudronnerie
on envoie les conséquences aujourd'hui
merci une question sur les projections à
peu près effectivement la période 2012
dans la suite des questions évoquées par
le président
à la fois sur les prévisions d'électe
consommation d'électricité et puis sur
la capacité à développer les énergies
renouvelables juste à votre place il y a
quelques minutes le directeur général de
l'énergie du climat qui était en poste
en 2012
nous a dit que les à cette époque les
prévisions de RTE sur la consommation
électrique
apparaissait crédible quels n'ont
d'ailleurs pas été
comment dirigeant validé avec le temps
puisque les prévisions à court terme
étaient assez stables et c'est ce qui
s'est ce qui s'est passé et que le
changement a eu lieu plus tard donc
première question est-ce que vous à
l'époque vous aviez déjà l'intuition que
ces prévisions n'étaient pas bonnes
est-ce que vous aviez connaissance
d'interlocuteurs qui eux savaient que
ces prévisions qui étaient pourtant
celle de RTL n'étaient pas bonne et ma
deuxième question c'est que
le directeur général de l'énergie climat
nous a expliqué qu'il avait fait le tour
des interlocuteurs en arrivant à ses
responsabilités j'imagine donc du PDG
d'EDF et qu'il a souligné le fait que a
déjà à l'époque le gouvernement qui
arrivait avait des objectifs très
volontariste en matière d'énergie
renouvelable et il a dit que ce scénario
lui apparaissait plausible y compris eu
égard aux capacités industrielles du
pays est-ce que vous partagiez à
l'époque cette analyse
la fin de la question c'est vous
rencontrez le nouveau DGC à la fin de
l'année 2012 il vous dit que les
hypothèses du gouvernement en matière de
capacités sont très importantes
qu'est-ce que vous vous en pensez en
tant qu' énergéticien
la France à cette époque-là
le parc du client français fournit à peu
près 75 à 80% de des besoins électriques
de la France
l'hydraulique à peu près 12 et demi pour
cent il reste donc Delta qui était
réservé soit au moins une pointe donc on
avait encore quelques strates de pointe
j'entends le fioul d'ailleurs qui était
dans l'ouest de Paris et puis quelques
centrales au charbon qui ont été ensuite
transformés en charbon propre d'ailleurs
donc on pouvait considérer que le
renouvelable avait potentiellement une
place à occuper et c'est la raison pour
laquelle
j'ai pris l'addition de prendre le
contrôle de DF énergies renouvelables
énergie nouvelle qui était de la filiale
dédiée d'EDF à 55 ans avec son fondateur
qui était Paris Sporto
considérant que il fallait d'abord
montrer qu'on était pas totalement
absent des nouvelles et qu'on n'était
pas
une équipe nucléaristes obstiné et que
d'autre part c'est moyen pouvait être
utilisé éventuellement en complément de
la capitale existante sans oublier quand
même que le renouvelable évidemment
intermittent que le stockage n'est
toujours pas disponible puisque nous
sommes de recherche considèrent encore
aujourd'hui qu'il faut encore 20 à 25
ans pour que le stockage soit
effectivement efficace en termes
économique et que par conséquent le
renouvelable reste une énergie
complexe à gérer à qui on accorde par
principe priorité d'action réseau mais
qui n'intervient que lorsqu'il y a du
vent lorsqu'il y a du soleil c'est à
dire bon ni la nuit évidemment
ni quand il fait très froid parce qu'en
principe il y a pas de vent quand tu
fais très froid donc le renouvelable
n'est pas utile en période de pointe
ce qui fait que l'injection du
renouvelable dans le système impose
une flexibilité au nucléaire que le
nucléaire n'a pas spontanément et qui
nous a coûté de mettre au point de
manière à ce que les centrales plus être
un peu plus flexibles puisqu'elles sont
en principe conçues pour des besoins de
base
voilà comment j'ai vu la part du
renouvelable
la France n'est pas un pays dans lequel
le renouvelable à une place considérable
à prendre
à mes yeux
du coup j'ai je j'aurais juste deux
petites questions et puis ensuite on
passe au membre de la commission
ces dernières années c'est entre 12 et
15 GW de capacité de production
pilotable qui ont été qui ont été
fermées
une partie
sous votre mandat comment comment ces
choix de fermeture de de centrale
pilotable bon bah Charmont fioul se fait
s'imagine ce conçoit l'échelle du
système et de et de la pointe d'abord ça
se conçoit longtemps à l'avance donc le
fioul on avait décidé d'arrêter parce
que parce que c'était l'énergie la moins
compétitive et
déjà dans les cartons comme devant être
fermé lorsque j'ai pris les manettes de
DF
le charbon
on savait que le charbon n'avait pas un
avenir très brillant si ce n'est qu'au
fond on avait réussi
nos équipes ont conçu des centrales à
charbon propres donc cordonnée en
particulier qui répond à toutes les
exigences en matière de qualité
environnementale et que par conséquent
on pourrait utiliser là par contre en
pointe ou un point
donc voilà comment l'édition se prennent
elles se prennent des années à l'avance
parce que il y a un problème industriel
et un problème social à traiter qui ne
s'improvise pas c'est pas des ce ne sont
pas des décisions qu'on peut qu'on peut
gérer la petite semaine c'est il faut
donc
un biseau dans le temps c'est
bien établi et au fond j'ai pris
quelques initiatives et j'ai appliqué
les initiatives des prédécesseurs dans
ce domaine là
voilà et est-ce que le critère de la
pointe à ce moment-là et enfin comment
vous prenez ce critère de la pointe et
il est essentiel
il faut que la capacité
de production puisse répondre
jusqu'à y compris la pointe
donc ça
sachant que par ailleurs comme il existe
des interconnexions notre capacité de
production occidentaire on arrive à
l'exporter assez facilement et EDF était
exportateur net d'énergie électrique
pendant toute ma période de
responsabilité alors la vérité c'est que
dans la même journée on achète et on
vend parce que on optimise mais
globalement et pour simplifier le sujet
EDF était
exportateur net d'énergie électrique
notre capacité électronucléaire tournée
la production électronucléaire tournée
autour de
420 430 terre
enfin à cette époque là et
l'hydraulique est assez stable puisque
l'hydraulique là encore une fois sert de
d'optimisation donc on voit que
l'essentiel du parc français répondait
aux besoins et que la pointe en dehors
de quelques rares exceptions de très
grandes pointes de froid l'hiver ou j'ai
vu
j'ai assisté à quelques réunions au
centre de dispatching vertte à
Saint-Denis
on évoquait l'éventualité de
au fond de délestage
partiels qui n'ont jamais dû à votre
demande enfin c'était prévu pour le cas
échéant répondre
à une crise éventuelle
on peut d'ailleurs jamais exclure qu'un
problème sur un des centrales c'est
arrivé l'été par exemple à cause des
baisse de régime de tirage des fleuves
et qui nous imposaient de par précaution
et soucis environnemental de d'arrêter
des réacteurs pour éviter que les autres
refroidissement ne pompe trop la rivière
concernée donc c'est arrivé mais sans
qu'il y a eu jamais de graves
dysfonctionnements
très bien dernière question
c'est sous votre mandat que
démarre le la prospective sur le projet
inclipoint comment est-ce que vous
imaginez à l'époque le la structuration
du financement
c'est un des trous la première étape
d'un programme nucléaire britannique qui
est en trois étapes
prévu négocier avec les pouvoirs publics
j'ai négocié personnellement
avec le Premier ministre britannique le
contrat digne de Paris
alors le financement c'est très simple
le contrat porté sur plusieurs thèmes la
construction directeur nucléaire de EPL
bien sûr
deuxièmement
j'ai réussi
à faire adapter par adopter par les
Britanniques un contrat
qu'ils appelaient eux contrats qui n'est
que l'application en droit britannique
de ce qu'on appelle nous contrat de
garantie de recettes dans le transport
public en France
j'ai calqué
ce schéma là c'est à dire qu'au fond
vous avez une bande passante tarifaire
qui est prévu si des prix de marché
dépassent la bande tarifaire alors c'est
une redevance qui est due aux
britannique et si un versement les
recettes ne sont pas suffisantes alors
vous avez droit à une subvention jusqu'à
jusqu'au de la bande passante c'est
exactement le contrat de garantie de
recettes à la française
donc ça c'est le contrat de base dites
troisièmement
j'avais négocié avec les Britanniques
que le tarif appliqué serait de 92
livres 50 mégawattheure quand à l'époque
je le rappelle le prix de marché en
Grande-Bretagne était de 40
contrat garantissant sur 35 ans les 92
livres
troisièmement j'ai négocié avec les
pouvoirs publics britanniques EDF soit
actionnaire à 45% seulement du projet
de manière à ce que nous déconsolidions
la dette de notre bilan
alors il manquait 55% bien sûr j'avais
tordu le bras d'arrivage je le reconnais
pour lui imposer de prendre 10% du
capital
sous les couilles de
Courcelles qui malheureusement
nous a quitté prématurément
mais en lui disant écoute c'est simple
le capital social sera de 5 à 7
milliards de livres 10% c'est 700
millions de livres je te donne un compte
sur commande à du concurrence ça tu as
pas de problème de trésorerie
il a finalement accepté et puis j'avais
trouvé des actionnaires chinois bon
j'étais allé vendre le projet en Chine
il y a deux acteurs chinois c'est CGN
CGN qui était notre partenaire
historique
CGNC qui sont concurrents enfin son
autre nucléariste chez nous
ça c'est fini donc évidemment comme
toujours
par un arbitrage du président chinois
routine Tao de l'époque qui a désigné
comme opérateur CGN mais en disant
o25 ans vous faites 55
et il voulait prendre 45%
. je pensais qu'avoir les Chinois 45% ça
poserait problème parce que je ne
voulais pas qu'il soit parité avec nous
pour pas qu'il y ait de conflit de
responsabilité
je vais convaincu les Saoudiens qui
avaient un programme nucléaire sous le
coude de 6 juin
avaient
choisi le groupe Ben Laden pour être la
représentant c'est vrai que j'ai eu un
succès mitigé
avec David Cameron quand je lui dis que
d'aller investir dans le nucléaire en
Grande-Bretagne
laissez-moi passer les élections il a
été battu donc
mais c'était ça l'idée c'était 45 % EDF
des consolidations
sujets se limiter d'une part au capital
social enfin cette manière de livres
c'est pas non plus la mer à boire 45 %
de 7 milliards c'est pas quelque chose
d'essentiel pour EDF
et puis le financement ne pose aucun
problème sachant que la dette de dire
autre élément de discussion était
garanti par la Banque d'Angleterre
pourquoi j'avais fait ça
parce que je me suis un contrat avec les
Britanniques bon il vaut mieux se
garantir et
je voulais qu'il soit solidaire de
l'équilibre économique du projet puis
bon les 92i 50 ne sont appliquées que
dans 10 ans j'étais optimiste sur la
construction européenne donc autant il
faut faire en sorte que les Britanniques
soient solidaires de l'équipe économique
et donc je leur ai demandé de garantir
la dette qu'ils avaient accepté de faire
donc le financement de poser guerre de
problèmes métaphysique
le contrat a évolué après mon départ de
manière très différente
d'où la démission de mon directeur
financier d'ailleurs
merci beaucoup on va passer au question
des groupes alors pour le
Renaissance il y a plus personne
monsieur Tanguy
[Musique]
merci monsieur le Président merci
Monsieur Proglio pour cette exposé très
complet qui coûte vraiment des sujets
très différents donc je vais je vais
essayer de essayer pardon de ne pas me
disperser dans dans mes questions vous
avez soulevé un au début de votre de
votre présentation à celui assez
original sur lesquels j'aimerais que
vous reveniez c'est le problème de la
rémunération
des professionnels et en particulier des
cadres aussi bien dans l'ingénierie que
dans la question j'imagine
susceptible de d'être gardé dans la
filière par rapport à la concurrence
mondiale qui évidemment s'opère sur les
cadres dirigeants et les ingénieurs
est-ce que vous pourrez revenir les
dimensions sur sur le cadre que vous
avez trouvé si effectivement ça vous a
posé problème dans la rétention de ta
langue qui ont pu partir de votre
entreprise aussi bien vers d'autres
entreprises françaises que peut-être
vers l'international et si le cadre
encore actuel tel que vous le connaissez
pose encore problème pour garder des
talents ou voir pour voir des talents
s'enfuir donc est-ce qu'il y a une
réflexion à mener pour garder notamment
les compétences qui sont formés en
France ou lequel chiant pour attirer
aussi des compétences de l'étranger dans
la reconstitution
de la filière ensuite vous avez parlé du
potentiel hydraulide de d'énergie
hydroélectrique qui reste à exploiter
est-ce que quand vous étiez président de
Dave vous avez transmis au gouvernement
des éléments quantifiés sur le potentiel
qu'il restait à exploiter aussi bien
pour la production d'électricité que
pour le le la mise en place pardon
l'installation de nouvelles step
ensuite vous avez laissé de de respecter
vos vos mots dit que vous avez assisté à
des décisions que moi je qualifierais
d'absurde sous votre regard et ensuite
vous avez dit que tout cela était prévu
les conséquences que ces décisions ont
eu comment et vous avez aussi décrit des
capacités d'influence de lobbying
qui ont réussi de la part de l'Allemagne
à travers l'autorité bruxelloise comment
vous expliquer
qu'une nation arrive à défendre d'un
côté des intérêts donc purement
nationaux à travers les flux européens
et qu'un versement des responsables
politiques qui étaient vos
interlocuteurs mais aussi des
responsables industriels ou des voire
des responsables administratives donc
ils sont même pas soumis à la pression
des élections qui sont par nature
unamovibles et protégée ne défendent pas
l'intérêt visiblement donc national ils
prennent même des décisions en pleine en
pleine conscience de cause contraire à
l'intérêt national et même contraire
alors propre intérêts presque parfois
égoïstes
vous avez ensuite parlé de des
conséquences financières de la reine
j'ai essayé à plusieurs reprises depuis
de nombreuses années aussi bien même
avant mon mandat d'essayer d'obtenir une
estimation de la perte financière
qu'a représenté la reine pour Dave
depuis sa mise en place combien EDF
parce que là on a une estimation quand
le quand on a une estimation je crois de
Melia de 16 milliards des Didas là de
pertes enfin je sais plus c'est plus les
chiffres en mémoire enfin là on a eu une
estimation quand le volume d'arène a été
augmenté et donc on a une estimation
pour une seule année de la perte que ça
représentait pour EDF alors là les
circonstances exceptionnelles mais en
période avant la crise du gaz et sont de
l'emballement du marché européen du prix
du de l'électricité européenne est-ce
que vous en tant que dirigeant vous
aviez estimé transmet au gouvernement
combien la reine faisait perdre à EDF et
donc bah par corrélation par projection
combien on a perdu sur l'ensemble de
cette année et évidemment les
conséquences que ça a eu sur la
pérennité et la capacité
d'investissement d'EDF au-delà de la
question du prix de l'électricité que
vous avez soulevé et bien expliqué sous
votre aussi vous avez commencé à évoquer
les questions de de fille industrielle
un sous les questions du président de la
commission
j'aimerais revenir dessus vous avez cité
donc la personne donc monsieur chrome
président à l'époque d'Alstom madame
auvergion présidente
d'Areva et Monsieur Mestral c'était en
tant responsable de de
l'époque pardon
vous avez vous avez ce phénomène mais
effectivement bon la filière
industrielle en tant que telle de
production matérielle industrielle s'est
ensuite effondré avec la vente d'Alstom
vous avez été entre d'une part vous avez
été président d'EDF entre deux
événements donc premier événement le
démantel le 1er démantèlement d'Alstom
sous impulsion bruxelloise au présentée
à l'époque comme un plan de redressement
pour moi mais là ça n'engage que le
parti que je représente c'était le
premier plan d'affaiblissement d'Alstom
et ça a mis les graines de ce qui ferait
son effondrement et le deuxième
événement c'est sa vente par d'abord
monsieur Montebourg et ensuite monsieur
Macron vous avez donc vécu la période
intermédiaire notamment les relations
entre à l'époque justement Alstom et
Areva puisque Alstom avait transmis
enfin on avait obligé à cet homme à
transmettre
Areva s'est transmission distribution
qui était une filiale particulièrement
rentable
al filière qui est finalement revenu à
Alstom qui me semble sous votre mandat
donc vous avez assisté ça en tant que
expert du domaine et ce que vous avez un
commentaire à faire sur la fragilisation
que ça pu faire aussi bien d'Alstom que
d'Areva et peut-être d'autres filières
comme power conversion peut-être
avez-vous connu ce dossier enfin d'une
manière générale vous en tant que que
acteur à ce moment-là est-ce que il me
semble aussi est-ce que le gouvernement
vous a demandé un moment ou un autre de
reprendre le contrôle capitalistique
d'un certain nombre d'activités
industrielles et ce que vous pensez que
ça aurait été une bonne idée votre les
dirigeants ensuite d'EDF ont visiblement
sous la contrainte pris le contrôle d'un
certain nombre d'outils industriels
faisant savoir au gouvernement selon
enfin en tout cas les informations de
ton dispose à travers la presse que ce
n'était pas spécialement le métier d'EDF
bon ça n'a pas empêché EDF d'acquérir
d'une part framatum puis ensuite
maintenant visiblement de récupérer les
turbines arabels qu'est-ce que vous
pensez de ces mouvements est-ce que vous
estimez que c'est le métier d'EDF ou au
contraire qu'il aurait mieux fallu
peut-être recréer un champion type CGE
capable de maîtriser l'ensemble de la
filière industrielle comme le font je
pense pas moi Toshiba il taxi enfin
d'autres d'autres conglomérats à travers
le monde
voilà ensuite et vous allez aussi autre
sujet industriel est-ce que sauf erreur
de ma part vous avez aussi sous votre
mandat à qui Photowatt ou producteur de
panneaux photovoltaïques français est-ce
que vous pouvez nous exprimer les
conditions de cette acquisition est-ce
que c'était une stratégie de votre part
c'était une demande de gouvernement
qu'est-ce que vous pensez de cette
entreprise et qu'est-ce que vous pensez
de manière générale puisque le Parlement
en ce moment est en train de voir la
suite de la planification
avec un une explication par 10 du
potentiel le photovoltaïque français
sans filière française qu'est ce que
vous pensez de de la stratégie qui a été
menée pour développer protéger surtout
ne pas protéger la filière française
quelle leçon en tant qu'industriel on
pourra en tirer pour ne pas que ça se
reproduise de la même manière sur le
sujet panli 2 est-ce que vous pouvez
nous éclairer sur les conditions de
négociations de pandieux
où en était exactement la négociation de
la même manière comment ça s'est arrêté
et aussi et ce sera ma dernière
conclusion pour l'accord de Fessenheim
il me semble pareil de mémoire que vous
étiez particulièrement
offensif pour moi existe titre dans la
défense des intérêts EDF et donc du
contribuable consommateur dans l'accord
de fermeture de Fessenheim il y a eu un
accord alors là ma mémoire flanche je ne
sais pas si c'est encore sous votre
mandat au-dessus de votre successeur que
l'accord final a été a été conclu
qu'est-ce que vous pensez de cet accord
de fois plus l'analyse du parti que
représente estime que cet accord est un
accord rabais qui n'a pas du tout
défendu les accords d'EDF et donc une
fois plus là est-ce que DF a en fait
payer à double titre par la fermeture de
son de son outil indus économique mais
en plus par l'acceptation d'un accord
qui n'était qui n'était pas fondé sur
des fondamentaux économiques qu'aucune
autre entreprise privée n'aurait accepté
ce que vous pouvez nous éclairer
là-dessus et vous aussi par rapport à
l'expertise que vous avez ce que vous
estimez que des étapes des étapes
définitives du démantèlement de
Fessenheim ont été franchis puisque
depuis une semaine on entend des voix
discordantes sur ce sujet je vous
remercie
merci merci
de répondre brièvement mais sans omettre
si je fais une mission merci de me le
dire parler de rémunérations c'est un
sujet extrêmement sensible et difficile
à aborder en toute état de cause parce
que
le public du mal à considérer que le
niveau de rémunération 4 dirigeant peut
être
[Musique]
pour faire une conférence j'ai dirigé
une maison qui était le général des eaux
devenus Veolia ou
j'ai eu la chance
de sévir pendant très longtemps
je suis parti cette maison compter
300000 collaborateurs chez EDF il n'y en
a que 180 000
mais l'atelier est très différente
autant chez Veolia on avait
20% de cadres et je ne maîtrise de 80%
de colle bleue autant chez EDF c'est
rigoureusement l'inverse puisque
l'essentiel des travaux sur sous-traités
et seul des activités de distrib surtout
distribution un peu de transport compte
des effectifs de colle bleue
significatif pour le reste chez EDF il y
a essentiellement des cartes dans les
agents de maîtrise le DF société mère
pour faire une juste vous remémorer un
chiffre
les coups de personnes def société
globale société intégré si je puis dire
si on pouvait continuer à intégrer des
distributions et la production
écoute personnel sont de 9 % de chiffre
d'affaires si on si on regarde
non 11%. si on regarde EDF c'est à dire
la production et la recherche enfin
l'essentiel de ce qui reste au
gestionnaire on descend à 9 % qui vous
faites 10% d'économie sur
la masse salariale d'EDF
l'impact sur le résultat
est modéré pour ne pas dire très faible
ça ne veut pas dire pour autant qu'il
faut pas le faire
c'est de chiffre difficile à manier
parce que soit vous les mettez sur le
place publique et au fond les gens vous
disent bon à quoi ça sert pourquoi des
grèves s'il faut
serrer un peu les éviter sur
effectivement
et en même temps vous voyez bien le
risque que vous prenez ne pas le faire
dans le faisant donc c'est assez ce
sujet compliqué
mais pour revenir au monde non pas
virtuel montre réel le fait est que
quand vous regardez la rémunération
des cadres supérieurs ou dirigeants
forcer de constater que le monde de la
finance est un niveau qui est
inaccessible par le monde de l'industrie
mais coefficient multiplicateur qui peut
être très important en tout cas
plusieurs fois
y compris chez EDF
et quand je prends la particularité
d'EDF EDF bon vous avez par importante
des salariés qui sont au statut et
d'autres hors statuts la différence
c'est que les hommes bénéficient donc
des avantages statutaires n'est pas les
autres et que les cadres rémunération
entre les deux est à peu près 15 %. et
non statutaire étant 15% mieux payés que
les statuts
ce qui rend la discussion sur le statut
encore
un peu sensible et je n'aurais pas de
mots simpliste pour évoquer les régimes
spéciaux comme d'aucun de printemps il
faut faire très attention à ce qu'on dit
bon
en arrivant en fin
d'une anecdote en fin 2009
quand vous arrivez à faire décembre fin
novembre début décembre vous vous
préoccupez quand même j'ai convoque ma
DRH dit écoutez on va passer le temps
qu'il faut je veux pas servir les cadres
pour voir mettre un peu dans l'oeil leur
leur profil et puis parce que ça va être
le moment des augmentations des bonus
c'est le moment de l'année où on se
penche un peu sur ce sujet mais vous n'y
pensez pas monsieur si si j'y pense
sinon j'oublie pas mais oui mais
il y en a beaucoup il y a même une
direction des cas dirigeant vous
comprenez alors je dis on passera les
week-ends des nuits y compris les fêtes
il le faut mais on va le faire je l'ai
fait
j'étais surpris du niveau relativement
modéré pour ne pas dire très modéré des
rémunérations d'EDF
et notamment dans nucléaire quand je
pose la question mais pourquoi en même
comprenez il y a pas de concurrence et
c'est vrai qu'il y a pas d'autres
nucléaires en Europe que la France
depuis que l'Allemagne a arrêté que et
donc sous prétexte là aussi vertu
du libéralisme et de la concurrence
puisqu'il n'y a pas de concurrence c'est
pas la peine de payer les gens plus que
ce qu'ils acceptent de l'être
c'est pas comme ça qu'on les recrute non
plus
donc j'ai essayé de corriger le tir
puisqu'il m'a fallu quelques remarques à
cernes de l'accord des comptes pour
guillau achète la paix sociale tu parles
il faut avoir ça en tête quand on parle
d'un sujet
long terme parce que la compétence de
demain c'est aujourd'hui qu'on a
construit
donc on a perdu les gens
continuent à en perdre
le patron du parc du glaire français est
parti dès qu'il ne peut prendre sa
retraite il est parti il était au statut
donc il a retraite et puis il est parti
au Canada j'irai une utilité américaine
ayant deux ou 330 nucléaires de
multiplier par 3 ça rémunération il vit
au cadastre et bien les impôts sont
inférieurs il y a quelques avantages
n'oubliez pas ça je crois qu'il faut en
toute état de cause savoir reconnaître
les mérites et la talent des gens et pas
uniquement en termes de concurrence
on n'est pas près du bord et je crains
qu'on ne fasse pas grand chose pour
faire évoluer le sujet en tout cas je le
dis de manière très sincère très simple
je j'ai découvert cette maison sur le
tas principaux ne devient pas président
d'EDF en démarrant et j'avais une longue
expérience de gestion
d'hommes et de talons je peux vous dire
ça et je crois qu'il fuyait très
attentif il faudrait que l'État il soit
plus attentif qu'il n'y ait aujourd'hui
c'est pas par le nombre
mais par le talent qu'on construit une
aventure
deuxièmement
l'hydroélectricité oui
je n'ai pas fait le recensement ni
portait à la connaissance des pouvoirs
publics les textes
je dirais exhaustif des opportunités qui
peut y avoir mais
il suffit d'aller sur le terrain auprès
des collectivités territoriales et eux
sont beaucoup plus à même encore que des
grands spécialistes de vous dire quels
sont les potentiels je sais que dans la
région niçoise dont je suis originaire
on peut
augmenter assez sensiblement les
capacités hydrauliques par des
investissements pas très important en
fait grâce au relief
et il donne chacune des régions
françaises je pense qu'on aurait intérêt
à ce que la coopération entre
les techniciens alors je dirais d'EDF
pour aller au plus simple
parce qu'il saute au moins opérationnel
et les responsables des pouvoirs publics
locaux se parlent encore plus qu'ils ne
font aujourd'hui pour faire justement le
détail des optimisations possibles et je
suis convaincu qu'on peut gagner entre
10 et 15% de capacité hydraulique ce qui
peut être extrêmement important pour les
années à venir
notamment les nouvelles step enfin
auquel vous allez faire référence
pourquoi est-ce que le bignone est plus
puissant que le Bing français
j'allais dire parce que je me souviens
d'un dîner avec un gala Merkel
au petit comité n'avait pas fait
l'honneur de me recevoir en tête-à-tête
mais c'était à l'inauguration de la
Foire de Hanovre j'étais avec le Premier
ministre français on était cinq de
chaque côté donc on était pas nombreux
je venais de vendre NBV notre filiale de
Berg aux Allemands un prix encore une
fois inespéré de cette manière d'euros
elle venait de sortir du nucléaire c'est
juste trois semaines après la session
arrêt Fukushima elle sort du nucléaire
et donc la société ne vaut plus rien et
moi j'ai ramassé 7 milliards donc j'ai
eu un procès avec des Allemands que j'ai
gagné enfin je reste qualité
vous avez fait une bonne affaire sur le
dos mais c'est grâce à vous madame la
chancelière pas pressé du tout si vous
êtes sortis du nucléaire donc
alors ça l'a beaucoup énervé elle m'a
dit monsieur
je vais être très clair avec vous
je suis une Allemagne de la scientifique
dans le domaine de l'Est je crois
totalement nucléaire
mais elle a été en pleine période en
d'élection régionale elle avait perdu
une langue mature mère justement etc
quelques grands viennent de rendement et
donc elle était en phase de
[Musique]
d'élection générale à haut risque et il
fallait qu'elle baptise un accord de
de coalition évidemment elle était
engagée dans une négociation avec le SPD
mais elle voulait avoir une alternative
parce que sinon elle était coincée par
le SPD donc ouvert une négociation avec
les verres conservateurs allemands chez
les Allemands de gauche c'est pas les
mêmes
et pour
pour boucler ce négociation elle a la
chaîne nucléaire
elle me l'a dit elle m'a dit je le fais
pour des raisons politiques pas du tout
technique ni scientifique
du coup Siemens est sorti du nucléaire
et toute l'Allemagne est sorti du
avec les conséquences qu'on sait sur sur
la France donc l'Allemagne est
consciente de ces responsabilités
l'Allemagne est consciente de ses
propres enjeux de ses propres
d'ailleurs personne ne parle en
Allemagne du couple font quoi allemand
il y a qu'en France qu'on parle du coup
franc quoi non donc
ça me donne le sentiment d'une femme
désespérée qui s'accroche à son homme en
disant on est en couple bon qui est prêt
tout lâcher pour que je coupe
l'illusion d'exister je pense qu'on a
rien à négocié contre le contre les
sacrifice de DF en tout cas je n'ai pas
connaissance de contrepartie que n'était
c'est pénible
je ne vois pas pourquoi la France ne
prend pas l'initiative comme l'espagnol
le Portugal de sortir du marché européen
d'énergie
pardon pardon pardon de cette image je
la retire
[Musique]
on peut se livrer à des calculs c'est
25% de la capacité nucléaire de DF c'est
à dire 25% de la production alors si la
production est normale c'est-à-dire 430
que vous vendez à 42 euros et après il
faut savoir quel est le manque à gagner
par rapport au tarif normal alors ça
dépend si vous référer au tarif régulier
qui était arrivé à l'époque au tarif de
marché
avec les vicissitudes d'un marché qui
passe de 50 à 1000
mais en tout état de cause le chiffre
est considérable
bien sûr
alors il est pondéré par le fait que à
cause de cela
la France EDF la France est obligé
d'augmenter les tarifs de vente aux
Français pour compenser le manque
parce qu'il y a une annexe à cela c'est
au fond rien de se faire une secrète
qu'est-ce qui fait que EDF a survécu à
cela parce qu'on a négocier des
augmentations tarifaires pour que
l'équilibre économique du groupe soit
préservé
donc oui c'est plus compliqué à analyser
finement que tout simplement faire un
calcul de multiplication et d'audition
mais
si quelqu'un pouvait faire ce calcul
même
approximatif et voir quels impacts sur
le coup de vent de l'énergie je pense
que c'est un sujet qui mériterait une
certaine attention
le mentalement d'un stock bon j'ai été
spectateur enfin je veux dire
franchement
juste votre propos parce que j'ai
assisté à des réunions à cette époque là
et Monsieur Montebourg a démissionné à
cause de ça
on peut pas le rendre complice de cette
action
il était révolté contre la vente de
la somme aux Américains bon
jeudi c'est parce que je n'étais témoin
et que je suis obligé
est-ce que c'est le métier de EDF non
non EDF n'est pas un industriel c'est un
architecte un sanglier gestionnaire
opérateur
mais qui sous-traitent la dimension
industrielle de ces éléments
constitutifs sont patrimoine industriel
a des entreprises spécialisées qu'il
s'agissent de BTP de chaudronnerie de
toute la partie industrielle avait
vocation être développée par la filière
pas par terre
bon voilà ce que je peux dire le reste
le commentaire bon
photo what oui j'ai essayé de sauver les
photos ouais parce que c'était la
dernière entreprise européenne et
française qui restait dans le domaine du
photovoltaïque et que je considérais
qu'il était devant devoir d'essayer de
la sauver bon je l'ai fait je le
reconnais les chiffres en cause étaient
ridicule par rapport au chiffre
manipulés par EDF c'est entre 15 et 17
bières d'investissement annuel donc
c'était marginal encore fallait-il
obtenir si possible que photowed et
petite priorité dans l'installation des
parcs photovoltaïques qui n'a pas été le
cas et donc aujourd'hui tout est chinois
et on sent satisfait
donc j'ai pas eu de stratégie de filière
française n'a pas existé
panli 2
fut un temps lointain ou dans les
arbitrages ministériels
[Musique]
pour les dédommager ne pas être
un acteur important de la fille
je reconnais avoir un peu réagi que pour
lui deux ne se fasse pas ne bave pas
fait pleurer
ne perdent plus en situation de
enfin c'était encore pire fait par Suède
qu'il n'avait aucune centrale nucléaire
en dehors des belges dont ils avaient
hérité par Electrabel dans son
patrimoine construire une nouvelle paire
c'était un peu psychédélique
j'ai réussi à le faire comprendre
on a enterré dans lit
avec les honneurs du
de ces promoteur voilà en gros
au moment je peux résumer
les réponses pardon si vous êtes un peu
rapide à ces questions diverses
merci bien monsieur
en séance ici dans cette noble maison
j'ai vu l'odeur de répondre à la même
question à l'époque en disant seul le
président d'EDF peut faire un état n'a
pas le droit c'est juridique
de fermer Fessenheim sans l'accord du
président de c'est un problème juridique
ça a été d'ailleurs entre-temps traité
et à ce titre je demande une
compensation
Fessenheim c'est 400 millions
d'habitants je me suis très précisément
des titres je j'ai obtenu 10 ans
d'extensions de la durée de vie de
façonnerie je suis sûr d'avoir les 10
ans suivant je demande à l'état 8
milliards de compensation puisque
j'avoue que c'est pas si difficilement
j'ai été très très lourdement
montré du doigt certains se sont réjouis
dans la salle je reconnais pas tous et
donc j'ai demandé 8000 je suis parti
avant que je fais ça
a obtenu 400 millions
je n'étais plus là
merci beaucoup comme député de
Fessenheim je ne peux que confirmer
certains chiffres monsieur Dubois
oui monsieur Broglio merci pour pour
tout ce que vous nous avez 10 et ça
éclaire énormément les choses c'est le
cas de le dire c'est un mauvais jeu de
mots le majoré simplement
une question courte mais demandons avant
mon arrivée il y avait un slogan de EDF
nous vous devons plus que la lumière ça
m'avait marqué parce que pour une fois
une entreprise disait devait quelque
chose c'est ça la contredit service
public on vous doit quelque chose et
plus que la lumière je trouve que c'est
un bon résumé pardon j'aurais dû
garder ce slogan
vous avez bien fait de reprendre la
parole c'est intéressant donc moi je
voudrais simplement revenir sur sur 2012
vous nous dites effectivement
le nucléaire produit 80 % le
l'hydroélectricité 15 % et les énergies
nouvelles le reste et
la pointe avec le il y a une campagne de
2012 donc je suppose que c'est parce
qu'on n'est pas précisé mais la campagne
des présidentielles qui qui donc dans
son programme annonce la fermeture de 28
réacteurs pour baisser donc à 50% la
production du nucléaire donc ce qui nous
amène à ce fameux mixte énergétique
finalement aujourd'hui à ce moment-là
j'aimerais bien votre confirmation sur
le phénomène en qu'on avait bien notre
souveraineté électrique et
qu'aujourd'hui nous n'avons plus nous
sommes toujours sur ce mix énergétique
et on se rend compte que dans ce mix
énergétique sur les EnR
l'hydroélectricité produit 49%. donc
est-ce qu'il vous paraît pertinent
[Musique]
à l'avenir de développer
l'hydroélectricité par ces fameuses
steps de pompage turbinage et comment
en tant que président d'honneur
d'électricité de France comment on
pourrait donc relancer des
investissements et notamment sur ces
steppes
et comment sortir de ce problème de
renouvellement des concessions si on
veut garder notre entreprise EDF
et pour en sortir quelle solution
proposeriez-vous si vous étiez
aujourd'hui président
d'électricité de France merci
ma diplomatie n'a jamais été mise en
cause comme vous l'avez compris je me
suis toujours exprimé de manière assez
carrée sans trop de nuances je crois
qu'il faut pas nuancer son propos il dit
hors de question que la France se prive
de ces bases
France doit dire à l'Europe
de
d'où sortent cette espèce de d'absurdité
qui consiste à dire que grâce à notre
relief et grâce aux investissements fait
par la nation puisque les barrages
appartiennent à la nation française pas
EDF qui dégère pourquoi est-ce qu'on
irait
donner
ça serait un gâchier épouvantable en
termes industriel économique puisque
encore une fois il serait acheté pour la
valeur de production et pas pour la
violence stockage qui est immatérielle
qui est la valeur d'optimisation donc il
faut simplement dire non
quitte à payer des amandes
les troupes belges vont envahir la
France donc on parle donc s'il s'agit de
négociera des amandes
mais il appartient à ce pays de faire
valoir ses intérêts vitaux
pourquoi c'est ce que j'ai plaidé
pendant tout la période de présence à la
tête de cette maison
d'absurde est-ce qu'on accepterait de
faire des appels d'offres de gestion des
barrages donc la réponse vous l'avez sur
sur les nouveaux investissements vous
savez ce sont des investissements
d'appoint c'est pas ça qui va être
fondamentalement
un élément de soucis pour EDF
ou alors c'est qu'on est arrivé à un
niveau de
désagrégation qui encore une fois EDF
c'est bon normalement 15 à 17 milliards
d'investissement annuel
il s'agit là d'investissement d'un point
d'extension de capacités ou de nouvelles
steppes je pars dizaines de millions
éventuellement par quelques centaines
que ça se traduira pas par des milliards
donc le sujet c'est plus un sujet de
recensement et d'optimisation qu'un
sujet d'investissement
merci bien madame Leernes
oui merci
quelqu'un
concernant la perte de la superbe de la
filière nucléaire française dans le
monde qui se découle sur un certain
nombre de fait précis notamment sur les
contrats perdus avec les Emirats Arabes
Unis l'échec commercial d'Abu Dhabi
pourquoi la filière nucléaire française
présentée comme le fleuron notre
industrie et référence mondiale en
nucléaire a-t-elle perdu en 2009 le
contrat de 20 milliards de dollars avec
les Émirats qualifiés comme imperdables
est-ce que le père était trop cher
est-ce que les difficultés rencontrées
sur les chantiers de Tyson ou de qui lui
auto en Finlande ont refroidi le
gouvernement émirien et plus globalement
de votre point de vue est-ce que c'est
difficulté ont entaché de manière assez
durable et de manière assez permanente
la réputation du programme
nucléaire français dans le monde ça
c'est une première question
liée à celle là beaucoup en tout cas
quand on lit les propos affirme que la
France a pendant des années arrêté
d'investir dans le nucléaire en France
pour faire le choix prioritaire de
l'exportation de l'EPR à l'étranger
notamment enfin Landes et en Chine
est-ce qu'on vous corroborez ces propos
là est-ce qu'on a privilégié
l'exportation avec des succès comme on
peut s'en apercevoir la géométrie
variable et au détriment des
investissements qui auraient été
nécessaires ici
sur un autre sujet sur les moteurs
diesel d'ultime secours puisqu'on a
parlé un petit peu d'Alstom
concernant l'appel d'offres pour
l'installation des moteurs diesel
d'ultime secours qui ont été remportés
par clemsy westing à 2013 il y a depuis
2014 de nombreuses voix qui s'élèvent
pour le contester notamment Yves-Marie
Lemarchand ingénieur en Génie Atomique
et ancien membre de l'ASN ainsi que des
ingénieurs de DF pour critiquer le choix
qui a été fait de choisir un prestataire
sur des critères de prix plutôt que sur
des critères de qualité technique
d'ailleurs il y a eu un certain nombre
de contestations y compris juridiques
j'aimerais savoir pourquoi ce choix
a-t-il fait été fait à l'époque alors
qu'il était clairement contesté et
compris par les experts du nucléaire
est-ce que vous avez délibérément fait
un choix économique au détriment de la
sécurité est-ce qu'il y a des autres
marchés sur lesquels EDF privilégier des
critères financiers au lieu de
privilégier la qualité technique et la
sûreté qu'est-ce que vous pouvez dire
aujourd'hui sur la qualité de ces dus au
regard de l'analyse qui en a été faite
notamment par Yves-Marie Lemarchand et
des multiples départs de feu notamment
en 2021 puisque sur ces du ciel non
seulement u des retards dans leur
installation mais aussi des problèmes
techniques et ces problèmes techniques
n'ont été signalés par EDF que plusieurs
mois après
le fait que ces problèmes soient étaient
survenus à la SN est-ce que c'est
symptomatique de la communication entre
DF et la SN et est-ce que EDF tarde
toujours à prévenir des défaits
défaillances techniques son agence de
sûreté c'est des choses qui me semblent
important de revérifier sur les liens
maintenus avec Rosa Tom
vous avez dirigé pendant des années
l'entreprise française de production
fournies
vous continuez à siéger dans le Conseil
consultatif international de rosatum qui
est le GR géant nucléaire russe qui
fondait par Vladimir Poutine vous dans
certaines
revues de presse on peut voir que vous
vous êtes également entretenu avec lui
aujourd'hui il occupe illégalement la
centrale de Zippo Riccia en Ukraine il
fait de subir des traitements inhumains
aux employés Ukrainiens il m'apparaît
donc légitime de vous interroger sur la
nature de votre poste au sein de cette
firme en quoi consiste vos activités
quelles sont les conseils que vous
pouvez apporter à cette firme êtes-vous
impliqué impliquez de près ou de loin
dans les accords cadres entre framatomes
et rosatum et est-ce que l'occupation de
la centrale ukrainienne est évoquée dans
ce conseil consultatif et une question
humaine pourquoi est-ce que vous
continuez à maintenir vos liens avec cet
acteur russe aujourd'hui pourquoi vous
ne démissionnez pas sur l'enjeu de
l'uranium retraité et donc avec toujours
les liens avec la Russie en 2013 vous
avez cessé l'activité de
réenrichissement de l'uranium de
retraitement parce que les pratiques
environnementales de ténex qui est la
filiale de rosatum avait été sévèrement
critiquée et parce que le procédé dans
les
usines russes semblaient insuffisantes
c'est ça c'est passé sous votre
direction comment expliquer vous
qu'ensuite les accords cadres et étaient
passés en 2018 pour reconduire cette
activité et de quelles compétences
manquons en France pour réenrichir
l'uranium de retraitement qui
justifierait qu'on conclut des accords
avec les entreprises russes comme
rosatum et Tenex
et enfin sur la Chine il y a eu et on
peut voir et on peut peut-être vous
interroger aussi si l'équipe du
nucléaire telle qu'elle était présentée
et les désaccords manifestent dont vous
avez fait état aussi lors de cette
audition avec la présidente du mot de ce
moment madame l'auvergon d'Areva en fait
sur les liens avec la Chine qu'a conclu
l'enquête de l'Inspection Générale des
Finances qui a été lancée en 2013 qui
devait déterminer si vous aviez fourni
des secrets technologiques nucléaires à
la Chine et est-ce que l'ouverture de
cette enquête aurait joué selon vous un
rôle dans le non renouvellement de votre
contrat à la tête de DF en 2014 puisque
manifestement vous pensiez être
reconduit vous ne l'avez pas été donc il
y a bien des raisons aussi au fait que
vous n'ayez pas été reconduit toutes ces
questions puisqu'on on parle
d'indépendance et de sécurité
d'approvisionnement énergétique au vu
des enjeux
politique vous avez tout à l'heure
évoqué aussi les liens avec les
saoudiens et notamment l'entreprise du
beau-frère de Ben Laden j'imagine bien
que les Anglais à cette évocation a eu
un mouvement de recul manifestement
l'État français en avait moins en tout
cas l'entreprise EDF et donc ça peut
poser un certain nombre d'interrogations
sur la place de l'État français et puis
surtout sur l'indépendance et la
souveraineté nos décisions y compris en
matière énergétique
pas de mystère ni de
ni de sujet tabou alors Abu Dhabi
oui j'ai vécu la fin de négociation
d'abudi je suis arrivé dix jours avant
la remise définitive des prix
EDF ne participe pas au groupement
qui avait été constitué par engie enfin
les pouvoirs publics de l'époque
sollicitait en disant faut venir parce
que là franchement
les émiratis étaient très déçus que Def
ne soit pas autour de table considérant
que la référence mondiale du nucléaire
cedf est pas Suez qui n'en a
pratiquement pas ni personne
et donc ils se sont sentis très humiliés
par le non présence def
par ailleurs il y a eu beaucoup de
maladresse le consortium en question
était constitué de gens qui
chacun tirait la couverture à lui donc
j'ai vécu ça en direct je pouvais pas
rentrer dans le détail nous avons perdu
Abu Dhabi parce que la France est mal
organisée c'est tout ni plus ni moins
c'est les Coréens qui l'ont emporter on
disait plus cher on avait aussi je pense
qu'on aurait eu des possibilités mais
il arrive qu'on place
la pierre à personne c'est ce lieu on
l'a perdu voilà est-ce que ça a des
conséquences non puisque les Coréens
c'est un petit groupe qui n'a pas les
moyens de construire le monde du
nucléaire et par conséquent on n'a pas
eu beaucoup de conséquences c'est
simplement un échec pour la France
alors est-ce que les investissements
dans le nouveau nucléaire
vous avez
vous avez parlé de nos clients donc ce
que
[Musique]
les mésaventures d'arriver ont empêché
EDF de continuer à investir non
donc
ça a probablement porté préjudice grave
mais c'est tout et plus ni moins donc
non il y a pas eu de choix de
l'international par rapport à la France
jamais
et je vous ai dit tout à l'heure dans
quelles circonstances et comment je vais
négocier le contrat britannique pour
vous éclairer sur la manière qu'on avait
que j'ai toujours eu
d'optimiser nos investissements en
réservoir à la France une position tout
à fait privilégiée et en faisant en
sorte que le développement
internationaux renforce le groupe mais
pas au détriment de ses capacités
d'investissement en France donc la
réponse est très simple
elle est non les dixièmes de secours ils
disaient de secours c'est des diesels
c'est ce qu'un moteur diesel c'est pas
de la technologie lunaire
alors il s'agissait de construire des
diesels pour
en fait c'est des
moteurs de secours pour produire de
l'électricité en cas de coupure en cas
de tsunami conséquence de Fukushima on a
construit partout ils comprennent
l'Alsace
donc
comment est-ce qu'on gère un appel d'Off
de ce type tout simplement avec une
commission d'appel d'oeuvre avec des
techniciens qui jugent si les gens sont
compétents ou pas alors il y a eu un
certain nombre de mauvais coups chers
qui ont considéré qu'ils auraient dû
être choisi
c'est possible
je souviens même de chantage fait par
l'entreprise human à Nantes qui
considérait que ça aurait été dû
ils ont fait un procès ils ont perdu
voilà
[Musique]
j'ai j'assume le responsabilité de ce
choix qui a été fait par ma commission
d'appel def auquel je n'ai pas participé
bon c'est tout entre temps j'ai quitté
EDF je ne sais pas si les diesel alors
qui ne servent que d'ailleurs
pour pour vérifier qu'ils sont qui sont
bien utiles une fois qu'ils sont
susceptibles de pouvoir être utilisés
jamais un diesel au secours n'a été
utilisé effectivement dans les centres
françaises puisque j'avais eu de coupure
d'alimentation donc est-ce que
cet investissement était utile ça se
discute on l'a fait un milliard est-ce
que c'était la bonne technologie je
crois en tout cas
est-ce que c'est un choix économique
probablement en partie encore une fois
c'est pas la technologie qui peut les
départager les gens c'est du béton et
des moteurs
comme
c'est ce qui est le cas non mais ce
qu'ils disent n'importe quoi
c'est ce qui est un diesel de secours
c'est un moteur diesel dans
dans
une une tour en béton parce qu'il faut
le mettre au dessus de certains niveaux
de manière à ce que si
si le terrain inondé ne soit pas
immergés voilà c'est pas non plus encore
une fois c'est pas le voyage dans la
lune c'est pas spécifique c'est un
moteur diesel
je reconnais que j'ai fait confiance à
mes ingénieurs pour choisir les
meilleurs moteurs diesel alors est-ce
qu'ils ont choisi en fonction du coût
rapport pour une performance oui sans
doute
[Musique]
le choix des prestataires là c'est une
itation pose toujours problème c'est
toujours pas monsieur faux
c'est faux
je veux pas passer une autre soirée sur
des moteurs diesel encore une fois
si vous choisissez une voiture vous
gardez le moteur c'est à vous de vous
orienter soit vous êtes compétent et
vous pouvez choisir du fait de votre
compétence soit vous faites confiance
des gens réputés compétents en matière
de moteur qui vous disent ces moteurs là
sont fiables ou pas c'est ce que j'ai
fait
pas raison d'acheter un V12 super
sophistiqué pour
monsieur rotor d'installation c'est
possible départ de feu c'est possible
aussi
on n'est pas dans une bosse on passe sur
les moteurs
je ne suis pas au Conseil d'arrosatoon
contrairement à ce que j'en dise j'ai
connu aux atomes du fait de ma position
chez EDF puisque mon interlocuteur
naturel c'était monsieur kerrienko
président de rosettum qui était
une culture courant avec lequel nous
avions des relations tout à fait tout à
fait agréables et efficace c'est un des
grands acteurs industriels de ce pays
puisque ces 300.000 collaborateurs c'est
probablement la plus grande industrie
aujourd'hui en Russie d'autres
technologies qui n'est pas sous sanction
je le précise le nucléaire n'est pas
sous sanction
ils m'ont fait l'honneur quand j'ai
quitté la maison EDF de Me
coopter un conseil consultatif
sur le nucléaire civique qui regroupe
des autorités de sûreté nucléaire
italienne
espagnol
japonaises
en italien un espagnol un Japonais
rue chez moi
une fois de temps en temps pour parler
des nouvelles technologies nucléaires
notamment des petits réacteurs
c'est intéressant donc voilà je ne suis
pas rémunéré
un petit peu que ça paye pas les voyages
donc oui on paye pas les voyages donc je
veux bien essayer de déclarer donc il y
a pas de problème d'impôts dessus
est-ce que j'en suis à 2000 euros non
donc si vous voulez je fais pas ça par
la paga je fais ça parce que j'y trouve
un intérêt intellectuel d'une part que
je connaissais journal depuis toujours
que je vois pas pourquoi je leur ferai
la frontière je démissionne
alors que ça fasse plaisir ou pas et ça
n'est rien d'inégal c'est encore une
fois le nucléaire est à part il n'est
pas compris et EDF et le nucléaire
français continue à travailler du
nucléaire russe et devra encore
durablement travailler avec
et chinois ne vous en déplaise
bon
j'apprends ces probable que quand
j'étais en poste on l'avait dénoncé
parce qu'il n'était pas suffisamment
compétitif ou pas assez efficace il a
été repris en 2018 vous me dites par mon
successeur et alors ils ont dû améliorer
leur traitement je n'imagine pas autre
chose c'est pas par complaisance
la Chine la Chine
il nous manque beaucoup de monde des
outils
c'est pas tellement les compétences
technologiques c'est les outils alors on
peut investir d'ailleurs la question se
pose faut-il investir pour être autonome
ou peut-on continuer à sous-traiter
la question
donc faut la paix poser aux ingénieurs
compétents du montant le question de se
poser même pas alors aujourd'hui elle
doit se poser
rationalités est-ce que on a la taille
critique et on est suffisamment
je dirais
suffisamment de volume pour pour
investir massivement dans ce sujet ou
est-ce qu'il est encore possible de
sous-traiter on soustraite à Wessing of
the américain on se traiteur russe
et qu'on soit autonome donc encore une
fois c'est un choix faire
bon dès lors qu'on maîtrise la
technologie après l'outil on peut dire
on a le temps de le construire c'est pas
ce qui est essentiel c'est la compétence
technologique on l'a
la Chine fameuse enquête qui n'a jamais
été publié parce qu'elle était
classifiée secret défense tellement elle
était meurtrière pour l'État qui l'a
commandité
moi j'aimerais bien la voir publier
j'aimerais
je le sais par un des membres de
qui a fait l'enquête qui m'a dit écoutez
c'est dramatique c'est bon
mais c'est pas grave
il y a pas eu de suite ça fait
ça fait plouf bon très bien alors n'en
profitez pas pour dire que espèce de
raison
sous-jacente pour que non pas du tout
d'ailleurs le principal témoin
interroger Monsieur Hollande vous dira
pourquoi il m'a pas renouvelé c'est pas
à moi de vous dire puisque c'est lui qui
a pris la décision après que sa ministre
m'amuse de tutelle et sa ministre de
l'écologie et de transition énergétique
mais informé du contraire ce qu'elle m'a
appelé en me disant je suis ravi j'ai
obtenu du président de votre
renouvellement
donc pas de débat et c'était bien après
cet épisode ou grotesque donc
après moi le Président c'est ce que je
lui dis parce qu'on s'est vu longuement
après cette décision écoutez c'est pas
la peine de prendre le prétexte vous
avez 85 % du capital il m'est arrivé
combien de fois de dire un président
d'entreprise dont j'ai le contrôle
écoute je suis très content de ton
travail mais j'ai besoin du poste c'est
tout
on va pas faire d'états je ne suis
propriétaire de rire j'ai eu la fierté
de diriger EDF je vais pas me plaindre
je suis pas une victime
voilà c'est tout c'est une décision
régalienne de quelqu'un qui est
l'actionnaire qui a le droit de décider
bon il a hésité puis il a dit oui puis
il a dit non enfin bon
ça arrive
donc
une vie passionnante je suis très
reconnaissant la République française tu
peux m'avoir donné cette chance voilà
on va pas épiler dessus mais je ne veux
pas laisser quelques esprits malsains
prétendre le contraire d'une mesure
logique mais pas
venimeuse pour dissimuler je ne sais
quelle turpitude
c'était le principal groupe saoudien
de l'époque le premier groupe saoudien
notamment dans le domaine de BTP et de
la construction c'est le groupe qui
avait choisi le Royaume d'Arabie
Saoudite pour développer le nucléaire
c'est pas un choix de premier
je rends à 16h ou roi d'Arabie si tu
reviens c'est son domaine il a choisi
nous a été désigné d'ailleurs
à nos bonnes bourg qui était ministre à
l'époque
m'a accompagné dans plus d'un voyage
pour justement pousser du clair français
en Arabie Saoudite il vous en parlera
par jour chez binodin qui avait été
désigné point final donc quand
l'Arabie Saoudite me dit je veux bien
venir et c'est bindle qui portera le
projet ça me paraissait naturel et
logique qu'après le nom de villenaden
sur connoté en raison de d'événements
que nous connaissons mais que les Arabes
saoudiens connaissaient aussi bien que
nous mais considéré comme n'ayant
ou qu'un rapport avec l'affaire en
question c'est en fait
les conversations que j'ai eu à l'époque
l'Arabie Saoudite vient de signer avec
les Russes peut-être ça vous a échappé
on a perdu une autre opportunité d'une
autre ampleur que les Émirats
peut-être qu'il aurait fallu être plus
présent auprès de
client potentiel pour développer du
clair français mais un avis très
personnel
voilà
très bien merci beaucoup monsieur le
Président
on en conclut donc cette audition je
vous remercie pour votre disponibilité
pour les réponses claires et
compréhensible de tout ce que vous avez
apporté à nos questions
nous recevrons demain pour poursuivre
nos travaux Monsieur François brodt au
titre des responsabilités qu'il a exercé
à la tête de RTE puis Jean-Bernard Lévy
qui qui vous a succédé je vous remercie
et
je souhaite à tous les membres une belle
soirée si vous voulez ajouter quelque
chose
juste me remerciements
merci de m'avoir donné l'opportunité de
de témoigner de ce que j'ai connu
sans prétention avec évidemment
espèce de vanité de vouloir servir le
pays j'ai défendu un certain nombre de
positions que je continue à porter
je n'ai pas toujours entendu mais c'est
assez naturel
en tout cas je vous remercie de votre
attention merci de m'avoir invité et
puis je reste à votre disposition bien
sûr merci mesdames et messieurs merci
beaucoup bonne soirée bonne soirée la
séance est levée